[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels
hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him you get a secret you get a secret
you get a secret and you get a secret
he's handing them out like it's candy
down at marlago our nuclear secrets all
around the world why wouldn't he he can
do anything he wants he has immunity
from anything you can't stop
him absolute presidential
immunity Jim Jordan thinks he has
absolute immunity too so does
representative stuby I'm gonna show you
a clip today of stuby stuby
dooo sty dooo thinking that you cannot
hold Trump accountable and the rules do
not apply to Donald Trump that is what
they believe they are telling it to you
right out [__] loud
I don't know how many times I'm going to
have to say it and show it to you but
boy boy boy boy am I right that they do
not think that the rules applying to
Donald Trump because they love
authoritarianism they [__] love
authoritarianism they want a dictator so
goddamn bad oh my God they want a king
they want a dictator and they want they
want that dictator to
absolutely make sure they have PE pure
blood in this country he said that [__]
too yeah he wants to purify purify the
blood in this country he doesn't want to
poison it he wants to purified holy [__]
you talk about some Nazi ass [__] that
these Nazis are doing you're if you are
not aware of this then you're not paying
attention to what you need to pay
attention to but I'm very excited that
at least one person on M
MSNBC has come around to the fact that
what I've been saying for years is that
sunlight is the best disinfectant Nicole
Wallace is coming around the host of
what is it called deadline White House
or White House deadline something like
that I don't know I don't watch the show
she's apparently on like two or three
hours a
day um something like that in the
afternoon she's finally come around to
the fact that yes you have to show what
this chucklehead says when he says
dangerous [__] so the country knows that
he's saying dangerous [__] that's how
sunlight works that's how disinfecting
it works it's why I do it here on the
Tony Michaels podcast every every single
week day Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours Nicole you should come visit
me I know there's MSN M MSNBC producers
listening uh so at least the host should
come visit or at least come listen get
around of how this is supposed to
[__] work Joe Scarboro must have
heard or someone heard
yesterday oh
man I listened to Joe talk a little bit
this morning I gotta go check in on
these Sun [__] how else am I going to
know what the hell they're saying or
what the stupid [__] they're doing now
someone pointed out that they put a they
put polls up on the screen on MSNBC too
to tell you how close it truly is how
close this race truly is and apparently
Donald Trump in this stupid ass
ridiculous poll that is all full of
[__] [__] I'm here to tell you it's
all rigged and lies the reason why the
media is posting it on the boob tube is
exactly what I showed you yesterday when
Joe Mansion was was placed on mourning
Joe with Joe Scarboro BYO labels to make
you think that this is really close and
we should have a choice you do have a
choice autocracy or democracy that's
your [__] Choice take it which one
are you g to choose what are you gonna
flip a coin on autocracy or democracy I
mean we see autocracy running wild
running rampant in the Republican
Party don't you see it I see it do you
see it because apparently Donald Trump
has crowned the next speaker he crowned
the last speaker the media is seeming to
forget this they're running around
looking for Jim Jordan this morning as
if Jim Jordan has no chance or and Liz
Cheney even tells us that Jim Jordan Jim
Jordan shouldn't be the speaker okay Liz
Cheney who voted for Trump twice it took
190 days to come to the floor of the
house when you were in leadership to
tell the world and get it on record that
he did not win give me a [__] break
man give me a [__]
break Donald Trump controls the
Republican Party hookline
Sinker and when they do the bare minimum
which is I don't know governing
sometimes sometimes it's just simply
telling the truth like Liz T Cheney just
told the truth that Trump lost that
should not be a that's not a very high
bar folks it really isn't a very high
bar
that Kevin McCarthy keep the government
open and that's the reason why Kevin
McCarthy is not the speaker today and
why Jim Jordan is gonna Ascend to the
speakership is it bad for our democracy
for Jim Jordan to be speaker yes is it
bad for the institution yes in the short
term these are not things that we want
but this is why you have to work your
ass off in this next election and the
election after that the election after
in the election after
that we have to band together to know
that democracy is on the line
here and really honestly this country
needs inoculated of these [__] idiots
these authoritarian idiots these
maglites these Nazis these Republican
Nazis we need to inoculate ourselves of
them and at this point one of the ways
to get rid of them in our in our
electoral body of
politic is to show the country what the
[__] they actually will do
or more essentially what they won't
do what they won't do is the most
important Point um because Trump is Hell
been on shutting the government down
that's what their authoritarian dictator
their musolini Jesus their mango
musolini Jesus wants he wants the
government shut down because he's a
delusional little petulant child and he
believes that if the government shuts
down then he can prevent being
prosecuted for the crimes of Espionage
and the crime of treason of trying to
overturn our election and obstructing
official proceeding also the crime of
fraud in New York financial fraud in New
York and stealing our [__] documents
oh yeah Rico charges in Georgia
too that's what he believes that if he
shuts down the government he can prevent
prosecutions from happening next year
he'll destroy the economy they'll
destroy the American economy and they
can blame it on Biden that is literally
what they want to have happen that is
what he believes it's delusional at best
but that is what he [__]
believes that if he shuts down the
government or gets the Republicans to
shut down the government because he's
the king he's the mugga
King so let him do it let them step on
the [__] rake [__] them they're going
to do it anyways if they elect let's
just say they elect another reason Reon
reasonable Republican it doesn't matter
Trump is going to have them in their
pocket the next speaker of the house is
not going to owe anyone anything but
Trump trump is the only
one that they will take orders from how
do you think we got in this situation in
the first
place so the American people need to see
what the danger is they obviously are
not paying
attention it's
obvious that the American people are not
paying attention otherwise we wouldn't
have Republicans in charge of anything
literally nothing cuz everything Trump
touches turns to liquid [__] [__]
absolute liquid [__] [__] it turns to
everything all of it Michael andell is
broke Mike Lindell is [__] broke that
guy spent his entire fortune on Trump
thank
you Trump destroyed desantis's career
Trump abs absolutely [__] broke Rudy
Giuliani which that's another story and
Mike glendell good good these are all in
the good category that we can put on
what Trump did I'm dead serious if
anyone ever ask you what is some good
[__] that Trump did he destroyed Ronda
sanz's career that fascist will never
[__] dream of being president of the
United States good he [__] ruined the
fortune of Mike Lindell that [__]
psychopath that goddamn lunatic that
[__] M pillow not
good [__] him he put half almost half or
more than half of the [__] proud boys
and oath Keers leadership in [__]
prison for decades good [__]
him he destroyed Rudy Giuliani
absolutely [__] destroyed Rudy
Giuliani this morning I guess the IRS is
putting a lean on one of Rudy giuliani's
houses in Florida because he owes the
government a half a million dollarss in
back
taxes
Rudy's broke so is Mike Lindell and the
other the
others that have spent their fortunes
and their time holding up this mango
musolini Jesus will be broke Kevin
McCarthy he's broke this morning
broken I you need to resign Kev is what
you need to do just
resign why not what what are you still
doing hanging around Washington no one
wants to [__] hear from you you're
grac speaker you're the first speaker in
the history of our country that was
vacated from their seat resign [__]
George Santos needs to resign [__]
these people need to resign it's enough
of this [__] Bob Menendez oh there's a
Democrat here we go Tony's gonna attack
the Democrats he needs to resign too
gold bars Bob needs to resign this isn't
complicated stuff it really isn't it's
not
hard but when you have Absolut delusion
running
around absolute [__] delusion Jesus
Christ the Republicans aren't I mean Jim
Jordan the guy who is about to be the
speaker of the house is asked this
morning how he feels about Donald
Trump's endorsement from CNN when the
question should be how do you feel about
getting an endorsement from someone who
shared nuclear secrets with an
Australian billionaire and they went
around telling 45 people all around the
world putting our National Security at
risk with our nuclear with our nuclear
secrets is that the person you really
want an endorsement for that's the
[__]
question that's the [__] question Jim
Jordan's happy he's happy to have the
endorsement for a Russian spy oh he's
[__] excited about getting an
endorsement from someone who commits
Espionage who divulges our national
security secrets are nuclear secrets to
foreign Nationals because they're a
member of his Golf Club
oh he's a he's actually a billionaire
this guy's uglier than a [__]
are all billionaires
ugly are they I don't think they are
there's got to be some billionaires that
aren't [__] ugly
right right am I right or is it just the
scumbag billionaires it's just scumbag
[__] you know like Elon and
this guy this this this Anthony Pratt
have you seen pictures of this guy Jesus
Christ he looks like death walking I
mean even rert Murdoch looks like he's
50 years younger than this guy I'm not
kidding you it's horrible [__]
horrible whoa [__] I mean ugly must be a
prerequisite for being rich I mean once
you get rich you think you'd have enough
[__] money you know what I mean I
mean maybe that's the problem maybe he's
just a thousand years old and there's
just nothing you can do like he's just
catching up to the guy I'm dead serious
ugly [__] I don't know who this
guy is I have no idea who Anthony Bratt
is I don't know Trump didn't know Trump
just knew he was really [__] Rich he
was a member of his club and by God the
guy wanted secrets so he was going to
give them to
him he wanted to get on the side of a
real billionaire you know what I mean I
mean he's got all kinds of financial
problems admitting that he's committing
tax fraud right out in the open also
that little chicken [__] [__] um he's
going to drop the half a billion dollar
lawsuit on Michael Cohen that's right he
doesn't want to be deposed on Monday not
because he doesn't want to be deposed or
he doesn't have time to be deposed he
can't be
deposed he's a line sack of [__] line
sack of shits it's really it's really
hard for them to be
deposed to give testimony I mean how'd
that work out for you Trump in this New
York Civil Trial how' that work out for
you in the egene Caroll trial huh how'd
it work out for you given deposition
underneath the subpoena because you're
you decided it would be a good idea to
sue somebody or it would be a good idea
to commit fraud or sexual assault or
defamation of somebody and then you be
forced to give deposition H I wonder how
all that's working out for him so I
wonder I wonder what it could be that
Trump doesn't want to say on Monday is
it that he just doesn't have time he's
got too much time that he's got a golf
oh other Trump news Jesus Christ is like
a [__] waterfall ain't it
godamn I tell you what
I tell you what there's going to be a
day where we don't have to talk about
that son of a [__]
anymore and and honestly until then we
need to we need to force this country to
and force feed them this nonsense on
this [__] idiot do you know how sick
and tired the country is g to get of
having to talk about this son of a [__]
you know how sick and tired they're
gonna get of hearing this motherfucker's
name oh my God and His whining and his
bitching oh [__] about how rich is and
how rich they don't say he is oh my God
this country is going to get sick and
tired of that [__] so sick and tired
they're going to go we're going to get
them we're gonna make sure they stay
[__] pissed make sure we stay engaged
and make sure we get out there and we
[__] get rid of this son of a [__]
once and for all not just him but all
his [__] lackes too [__] him it's
time it's time to get rid of this [__]
this mlite [__] listening to these
[__] brainless toothless idiots
you're not going to change their minds
you're not going to change the cultist
minds they're a cult it's a [__] cult
you're never going to change their mind
it's not going to happen so stop trying
to change their mind let's just [__]
get together and go you know what we can
just get rid of them that'd be a good
thing just get [__] rid of
them what other what other news oh yeah
Trump gives an interview where he's
talking about how um brown and black
people are poisoning our blood H I
wonder if I wonder if that's sounds like
Nazi Germany in 1930 H wonder I wonder
if someone planted that seed inside his
brain probably Stephen
Miller that [__] GBL looking son of a
[__] yeah that's right I said it Steph
Miller is a Nazi and he's probably
planting these blood poisoning ideas in
Trump's head Trump didn't come up with
that [__] yeah there's no way he came up
with that [__] I'm going to show you the
I'm GNA show it to you I'm gonna show
you I'm G to show you you oh boy I got
some thank yous to give uh let's see
from yesterday we had a couple hat
orders [__] them hat orders if you guys
want some [__] them hats go to the Tony
michaels.com it's a good way to support
the show and it's a good way to show
your descent uh while you're out and
about [__] them [__] them [__] them so H
Derek and KJ thank you for the orders
also we had several shots bought
yesterday and we had some venmo chats uh
come in if you guys want to get in on
the venmo chat now just go to the Tony
michaels.com let me show it to you here
here's how you go you just go to the
tony.com hit subscribe at the top each
and every day's current episode is right
there at the Top If you want to buy a
shot that's how you can support the show
The benino Super Chat is right here you
can also put some money in the swear jar
if you like the word [__] too much you
can also help support the show with
memberships on patreon Discord and
twitch you can link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account and
here's where the [__] them hats are
right here it says [__] hats really easy
you just click that link you'll go to
the hat store or you can go to the merch
store check out the merch there as well
so thank you for all the orders that you
guys have placed and all the support you
have given you guys are the shareholders
of this show this microphone right here
could not stay on without your support
whether it's monetary support whether
you're buying merch or you're showing up
every single [__] day two full hours
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Facebook
and twitch that's right we're on YouTube
don't forget to hit the Subscribe button
it's free 99 hit the thumbs up while
you're here and if you don't like what I
have to say hell hit the thumbs down
button too who gives a [__] also follow
us on Facebook at the Tony Michaels and
follow us over on Twitch it's free to
follow us on Twitch but if you want to
subscribe you can use your Amazon Prime
account go to twitch.tv/ the Tony
Michaels subscribe with that one free
subscription you get with your Amazon
Prime account if you need directions on
how to do that just go to the Tony
michaels.com I've got a message here
from Bill e Boy on YouTube Billy boy
says hey Tony [__] Maga well great now I
must visit the swear jar too you
grifting [__] hillbilly thank you
Billy boy for the contribution on vinmo
chat and thanks for throwing some money
in the swear jar since you're since
you're such a [__]
Heathen Billy Boy on YouTube thank you
very much for the contribution in the
venmo super chat if you guys want to get
in on the venmo Super Chat you want your
message to appear on the screen just
again go to the Tony michaels.com hit
that [__] Super Chat link right there on
the
website okay what else news do we got oh
yeah Hillary Clinton's out um talking
again why why why why just just just
Jesus [__] Christ I'm gonna show you
what she said yes I'm gonna show it I
don't want to show it but I'm gonna show
it it the rightwing is [__] talking
about it oh my God and they're oh man
look look look the fascists are gonna
are going to deprogram us I mean you all
need to be [__]
deprogrammed you bunch of goddamn Nazis
you delusional pieces of
[__] so I'm gonna show you that clip I'm
also gonna show you the the clip of
stuie the house Republican who thinks
that rules do not apply to Donald Trump
literally he says rules don't apply to
Donald Trump I'm also going to show you
a clip of Greg gutfield on Fox News
saying they don't want elections
elections don't work they don't want
elections they're saying it out loud
they're saying it out loud I don't know
if you're [__] paying attention but
they're saying what they mean out loud
also I want to show you a clip of Ronda
santis who is Ronda Sant why am i
showing this clip of Ronda santis again
is he relevant uh I just want to show
you this clip because he wiped snot all
over his face that's literally the only
reason I want to show you the clip of
Laura lumer though absolutely owning
Ronda santis I'm telling you it's
[__] delicious oh it's so delicious
I'm also gonna speaking of delicious
Clips I'm gonna show you a clip of Mike
Lindell admitting he's [__] broke and
he can't afford an attorney so all his
attorneys left his ass because he has no
more money left oh baby let's keep going
with that I'm gonna show you clips of
Liz Cheney Liz Cheney and I'm going to
give you why you shouldn't give a [__]
what Liz Cheney says anymore that's what
I said I said it a lot of leftists are
going to be holding up Liz Cheney as a
hero oh she's a [__] hero listen
doing the bare minimum for our democracy
the bare minimum is not a [__] hero
in my book and nor should we parade
around acting like Liz Cheney is some
kind of [__] hero we're gonna regret
it if we're not careful I'm telling you
it's G to happen you're going to regret
that [__] you're going to regret it
we're going to go over the story that's
broken ABC news about the Australian
billionaire who Donald Trump gave our US
nuclear submarine secrets to because you
know he's a rich member of maral Lago
now we're gonna watch Walther Masterson
uh troll the moms for Liberty I want to
show you that clip today I'm hoping I
can get to all this um because we got
bonehead too like we got a lot of stuff
we got a lot of stuff going on and man
got a lot stuff lot of stuff because I
gotta get to get a clip of Jim Jordan
talking about how he loves the
endorsement of of Donald Trump I got
another clip of Mike Pence talking about
[__] but one more thing before I go I
want to do what I told you so oh man I
want to do I Told You So several weeks
ago Glenn Kushner he's a he's a he's a
former United States Attorney oh he's
got a great YouTube channel he gets all
kinds of clicks and likes on his videos
Glenn's a smart guy I actually believe
Glenn's a smart guy he's a smart guy I
just don't know why he did this weeks
ago he put out a video about how he
believe that the secretaries of states
in this country could use the 14th
Amendment to unilaterally keep Trump off
balance well I missed it but a few days
ago the Supreme Court told one of the
cases to [__] off that that is not a
thing it's almost like I said that it's
almost like a lot of people
yeah a lot of people Chris here look
Chris on YouTube's like I love Glenn
yeah yeah and a lot of you g to be mad
that I'm running laps but I'm gonna run
some [__] laps here and the reason
why I'm gonna run some laps here isn't
because I don't like Glenn I like
Glenn I like Glenn I think Glenn is
valuable in the political
discourse but when you say stupid [__]
when you tell your your audience
misinformation and outright kind of Lies
just it's a [__] lie it was dumb it
was stupid it wasn't going to be a thing
and yeah I know you're going to come at
me like oh but Tony there's three more
cases folks the Supreme Court would even
hear the case secretaries of State in
this country do not have unilateral
power to use the 14th Amendment to keep
one person off the boutot because they
do not like them that is not how it
works that it's not the road that
democracy wants to go down it's one of
the reasons why we have such a tough
time today we shouldn't be giving one
person more power we should be giving us
the government We the People more power
than one person it's what the
Republicans want to do with project
2025 they want to give the president all
the power of the government the entirety
of it enti the total unilateral power is
what they want to give to the president
of the United States that's what these
Republicans want because that's the slow
walk to Fascism and this idea this idea
that we have that we don't like Trump
and it feels good that we can for teeth
him and keep him off the ballot we may
for teeth him one of these days there
may be a constitutional mechanism that
we can use to 14th his ass at this point
that constitutional mechanism doesn't
exist I know you want it to I know you
want it bad but just because you [__]
want something doesn't mean it's
true and I told you I told you and and
listen I went about it for several days
and people in the chat were pissed off
at me oh my God I heard it for days how
people were pissed off at me I don't
give a [__] I don't care if you're mad
about the truth I don't care I don't
give a [__] if you're mad about the
truth be mad just know the truth that's
what [__]
matters we can be mad about the truth
that Trump's going to be the nominee we
can be mad about the truth that Trump
actually controls the house chamber
we can be pissed off about that we can
be pissed off about the fact that Trump
is just willy-nilly telling anyone and
everyone our [__] nuclear secrets we
can be mad about it it doesn't mean it's
not the
truth it's the [__]
truth and to tell your audience Glenn
and I'm I'm chastising him here and let
me tell you something let me tell oh see
here here we go here we go silly Wonka
says I don't understand Constitution
law understand constitutional law listen
you do not have to you do not have to be
highly educated to know that secretaries
of State in the states don't have
unilateral power it's never been done it
never will be done I hope I hope it's
never done that way because if we do it
that way the foundation of our democracy
is
chipped that's the point we can't
sacrifice our democ Ry for the short
term of
trump we the people can get rid of trump
we the people can 14th his ass it is our
responsibility it is our government it
is our constitution it is our nation
it's not his it's not one Secretary of
State it's not it is [__]
ours and that's the point that's where
it goes wrong that's where it goes south
that's why you got to stop relying on a
judge or Jack Smith or the doj or what
Glenn says about the 14th Amendment
because it makes sense oh it makes sense
to the little 60- second
video didn't even give them the time of
day in a federal court didn't even give
them the time of day in the Supreme
Court
folks I'm here to tell you Glenn's a
smart guy and Glenn's a fighter he
should be a [__] fighter
but when you're fighting the wrong
fights it it it may it may suffer the
battle and the battle we have is the
battle at the ballot and it is our
battle to have it is so [__]
important it is so
important to fight that
battle and to not give it away or
capitulate to some
idea that is going to set us back back
in this country and hurt our
democracy it is important that we stay
focused on the goal it is super
important and silly Wonka you know I I I
I I hope you keep dissenting I hope you
keep saying that I don't understand
constitutional lie I hope you keep doing
it keep coming back and proving me wrong
do it I love dissent I love people who
love to hate
me I'm not always going to be
right but it's not hard to be
right not in this day and age it's not
hard to see misinformation the way it is
lies the way it is and know that that
misinformation and lies is going to
catch up to the people who disseminate
it it's going to catch
you and that's all I'm here to do is to
point it out regardless of who's doing
it or who's hurting our democracy I
don't believe Glenn hurts our democracy
but I believe that his content hurts our
democracy when he says things that just
aren't
reality we do not need to give people
hope we need to give them
fight if we sit back and just wait for
someone else to save us and have that
hope in our hearts and believe that have
having only that hope will save
us the fascist will
win there was hope for years in
Europe when Hitler when he walked into
Austria there was
hope when he marched to Poland when he
went to
France and
until Britain and the United States
brought the fight and then Russia joined
us in that
fight that's when it
started to beat back on the
misinformation and the lies of Nazi
Germany and started to throw a wet damp
blanket on the misinformation and lies
of Nazi
Germany we can't wait that long folks
and we can't have that kind of stupid
ass hope and misinformation in our
[__] National narratives
that [__] that Joe scarber tried on
us the other day of no labels [__] you
Joe now that Nicole Wallace is finally
coming around that you cannot ignore
what Trump is saying you cannot ignore
it just because you don't like it just
because you want to stick your fingers
in your ear I get this all the time on
Twitter when I post a clip people like
oh you're only promoting this I'm not
promoting it I'm showing you that it's
happening
how do you wake up in the morning do you
wake up in the morning because hope gets
you up or is there an alarm that goes
off that wakes you
up which is it sound the alarm that's
all I'm saying let's get it going and
let's get our fight in [__] hope [__]
hope we can have hope after we're done
and we win this battle at the
ballot and I'm I'm glad you're here and
I'm glad you
desent that is the tenement of a good
democracy don't go anywhere you Des
centers we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 6 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed because there's no good way to
keep them from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast
wow wow wow
wow oh people are mad at me oh man Tony
why would you bring a listener up on
stream because they disagree with
you cuz they disagree with me and it's a
healthy disagreement that we need to we
need to make sure that we
have that disagreement it's very
important who else is going to push back
on this idea
everyone else in the media was like oh
yeah Glenn oh yeah yeah that's great
it's not great it's [__] it was
complete utter [__] and Glenn Glenn
should apologize for it he should
apologize for lying to you because it
went nowhere and it's gonna go nowhere
it's gonna go nowhere and I want Glenn
to be doing content like he normally
does informs his viewers of [__] that's
real [__] that's out there there's
plenty of stuff to do content on plenty
of stuff you don't need to
sensationalize stuff that isn't [__]
real and I'm glad you're
here I'm glad you're
here and I'm glad you descent and I'm
glad you engage even if it's just to
come here and beat me up keep coming
back keep coming C back keep coming in
the chat keep beating me up uh silly
Wonka keep coming back to the show I
know you you might not um because I'm
going to challenge you but that's the
purpose is to challenge you it's to
challenge you as listeners is to
challenge you as members of this
democracy it is to challenge you as
soldiers in the pro-democracy Coalition
who want to go to the battle of the
ballot like this is the most important
election of our lifetime and one of the
reasons why is because there's an
authoritarian in charge of the House of
Representatives I'm not [__] you
watch this [__] watch this oh well maybe
hang on let me let me get let me get the
right screen up here and then we'll I'm
gonna show you Jim Jordan here this
morning when he was asked again it's
kind of the wrong question that was
asked um but I'm gonna show you this
question that he was asked this morning
here it is here's Jim Jordan on if he
likes the endorsement of a guy who gives
away our national secrets and commits
Espionage I appreciate the president's
endorsement he's the leader of the party
he's going to be our our our
Presidential nominee and I think he's
going to be our next president so I
appreciate that um but we're focused
also on you know the key thing is our
our colleagues and I'm talking with um
you know we got from from Freedom caucus
to people in the middle to to committee
chairs to Jeff vandrew who was Democrat
four years ago we got all kinds of cross
theboard support and we're just going to
keep working oh Jim Jordan what is with
the [__] hoodie are you really
seriously walking around the halls of
congress with a hoodie on you son of a
[__] bit [__] I've been hearing from
Republicans for weeks and weeks and
weeks how an elected official cannot be
walking around in a [__] hoodie that
it's treason or some dumb [__] right Jim
I don't report sex crimes Jordan is
walking around in a goddamn hoodie
around the capital what the [__] what
the [__] are you are you fedman or
what obviously I'm joking I don't give a
[__] what they wear and this is kind of
a step up from what Jim Jordan actually
wears but that's not the point here's
the point Jim Jordan I don't know if you
noticed his his tone and his demeanor in
this this little clip here but he seems
defeated you would think if Jim Jordan's
like oh the leader of our party the
mango musolini Jesus endorsed me and I'm
gonna be the speaker yay woohoo I get to
be the speaker woohoo Jim Jordan doesn't
seem excited at
all he doesn't seem excited at all does
he
it's almost like Jim Jordan now realizes
who owns
[Music]
him oh man I I can't with the
[__] the reason why Kevin McCarthy
is not the speaker in the house anymore
is because he didn't shut the government
down on the behest of Donald Trump the
reason why Jim Jordan is going to be the
speaker of the house is because Donald
Trump says so
the reason why Matt gats went to the
floor to bring a motion to vacate is
because Donald Trump told him
to folks this is not complicated this is
what authoritarianism looks like this is
why they're [__] drowning and when
your political opponent is drowning you
throw that son of a [__] an amble as
James Carville
says so start throwing them the Anvil
right [__] them
let them select Jim Jordan as the house
do you think do you think that he's
going to be any better at being the
speaker on the house then he is the the
chairman of the Judiciary Committee have
you watched him be a chairman in a
Committee
hearing the Democrats own his ass every
single time every single time they own
his ass so why am I supposed to be
afraid of Jim Jordan going against
Democrats in the house
100% he's going to lose every time and
there's the attitude now U there was a
lot of talk about Donald Trump being the
speaker of the house which Donald
Trump he doesn't actually have to hold
the office of speaker of the house to be
the speaker of the house that's how
authoritarianism works I don't know if
you know this I don't know if you know
this but when you have someone who has
unilateral power over a group of people
or an institution like the Republican
party then what happens is they don't
actually need to assume the offices of
those those the pillars of power to do
their bidding why would Donald Trump
want to go work and be the speaker of
the house when he could just install his
[__] little minion cult member like
Kevin McCarthy or Jim Jordan and bark
orders at them and then when they don't
do what he says to vacate them and force
another member who apparently Matt Gat
was walking around the house for now
this is according to a republican Mark
Wayne Mullen now a senator from Oklahoma
saying that he was showing videos of
underage girls that he was having sex
with on the house on the house floor
folks those aren't my words those are
Mark Wayne's
words why in the [__] would Donald Trump
want to be the speaker when he's already
the
speaker
why why would he want to assume the
office of speaker of the house and have
to go to Washington and work
when he could just install his minion
and bark orders and they do the work for
him huh why why why would we want to do
that but they played with this idea they
even played with it on Eric Bolan show
with Stuy dooo the representative from
Florida doesn't this guy look like an
[__] this guy looks like an [__]
he looks like a male Karen what is a
male Karen called by the way I forget
and there a name for it a lot of people
get pissed off when when I say Karen
because like ah it's
derogatory but he looks like a Merl
Karen doesn't he doesn't he this guy
looks like he would go into like a a
Smoothie King and lose his mind a Chad
some people are saying Carl some people
are saying Chad Kevin it could be um but
Stuy dooo here he's gonna tell us how
rules don't apply to his mango musolini
Jesus I'm not [__] you this is
important the reason why I'm showing
this clip is because they do not believe
rules apply to Trump listen to this fox
doesn't like Trump and he said something
like well there may be a rule where if
you're under indictment or you're some
sort of felony indictment before you
even convicted that you can't run for
speaker Congressman I think is there a
rule that I don't know about um so the
Republicans don't have a rule that well
there is a rule in the house that a
House member can't be indicted but
Trump's not a member of the House and a
lot of people don't know this but a
non-member of the house can actually be
the speaker of the house he's not going
to be again why in the [__] would would
Trump go work why would he do that why
the [__] would he do that when he could
just control Jim Jordan but let's listen
to what stuie has here here says about
the rules and how they apply or really
don't apply to Donald Trump I will nip
that in the bud right now because I've
seen Democrats tweeting that back at me
first of all Trump wouldn't be a member
of the house so at the current moment
rules don't apply to him because he's
not a member of the House and oh rules
don't apply to him okay all right yeah
rules don't apply to him rules don't
apply to him what would you do if the
rules did apply to him huh what would
you do sty
dooo what would you do the rules apply
to a member of the house and I can
guarantee you that if that were to
happen we in the majority we can change
the rules at any time there are things
that we can do to change the rules and
it will not be a problem well it will
not be a problem we can make sure that
the rules do not apply to Donald
Trump there you
go I don't
I now you would say well Tony he's
talking about house rules about the
speaker he's not really talking about
rules in general oh really he's not he's
not is he is he not talking about rules
in general because I really believe that
that's probably what he's
saying rules in general because that's
kind of their stance on Trump isn't
it isn't it or am I off my
rocker it really seems like it I mean
when you listen to Fox News speaking of
Fox News here's Greg gutfield on Fox
News let's see what he has to say about
elections I bet he really admires and
values American elections let's listen
but only certain people get criminal
Mulligans and January 6 protesters they
don't get Criminal Mulligans and here's
why they're the oppressor right so the
oppressed get criminal Mulligans the
people that are complaining like us were
actually oppressors and we we're losing
power so that's why we're upset I just
got a job at MSNBC but okay so when he
says this he means white people and
black people he means we who are the
oppressors are white people which you're
right Greg you're [__] right now he's
trying to make fun of it right he's
trying to make fun of the idea that
white people are their op pressors but
obviously Greg didn't go to history
class he thinks he's funny he's not
[__] funny this is not funny this is
not a funny diet tribe that he does hear
about our elections um but go on let's
oblig him for a minute but let so let's
compare the rights between criminals and
victims okay the criminals they get a
mulligan they get okay okay now wait
wait wait I'm I'm gonna I'm gon to stop
him there because what he means is not
criminals he means black people okay he
means black people because he just said
before why doesn't the January
6 insurrectionist get a mulligan why
don't they get a mulligan oh but the
criminals the criminals get a mulligan
we know what you're saying Greg keep
going though we know you racist piece of
[__] let's keep going to steal up to
eight8 $900 worth of stuff they can
loiter sleep and shoot up in public
areas including playgrounds they can
Loot and burn and call it social justice
uh they can uh pile up dozens of arrests
and never Due Time meanwhile what about
us well we have to what about us what do
you mean Greg what do you mean us what
do you mean what do you mean us let's
find out what he means change our lives
to accommodate risk wherever we go we
have to move out of cities for the sake
of the safety of our families and our
own safety that's what's happening we're
we should be afraid of black people oh
we watch have to be afraid of the blacks
that's what he saiding saying you white
people who are out there listening to me
should be terrified of black people
that's what that's what he's saying you
can't live in this the cities the urban
area the the black areas anymore you're
you're scary you should be scared being
driven out of cities by the oppressed so
by the oppressed right the black people
that's what he means get it right Greg
just say what you mean you [__] idiot
turn to my imperfect analogy from
yesterday we had a war over slavery we
knew slavery oh and you thought I was
getting out of turn when I was saying
that Greg means black people here he is
right after he's talking about the
oppressed looting stores and that
oppressors need to be afraid of those
oppressed now he's getting into slavery
H I wonder what he could possibly mean
by oppressed and oppressor I wonder what
he could mean by it surely I took that
that out of context was inhumane and
immoral but somehow we couldn't solve oh
oh oh but did you hear that he's like
slavery was inhumane and immoral but I
mean but am I right
but but but what [__] slavery
peacefully listen over slavery we knew
slavery was inhumane and immoral but
somehow we couldn't solve slavery
peacefully it oh oh it's almost like
it's almost like the
oppressors the white people the slave
owners in the South decided to have a
hot War because they wanted to own other
human beings it's almost like that
happened it's almost like it was called
a certain War here in America I think we
refer to it as the Civil War here in
America this guy's such a [__] idiot
it was an evil but one side refused to
acknowledge that it was was evil because
it was too big of an admission for them
to make doesn't that feel that way now
that this defant ref so now white people
are the slaves are you catching this are
you catching what he's trying to do here
he's trying to do that reverse
psychology where he's like oh we're no
longer the
oppressors we are the oppressed you see
that they want to be oppressed Greg
gutfield wants to be the oppressed so
[__] bad doesn't he oh my God he
wants to be the oppressed so bad he
wants to be funny too but he's not that
either fusel to reverse this decline
argues against the survival of a country
what does that leave you with it leaves
you with you need to make war to bring
peace because you have a side that
cannot change because then that means an
admission that their beliefs have been
corrupt all the time wait wait wait wait
I think I know where Greg's going with
this it sounds like Greg's saying that
hey we can't peacefully
have a have an agreement us whites and
then blacks the oppressed and the
oppressors but we can have War maybe we
just need to start you know having war
it feels like that's what he's saying
does it feel like that's what he's
saying to you does it feel like that's
where he's going so in a way you have to
force them s to surrender or war ah I
tried that once oh we have an election I
had to go to a doctor okay there there
it is we have an election maybe that's
what we do in democracies H we don't
just shoot and kill each other because
we don't like each other maybe we have
elections let's see what Greg has to say
about that election no elections don't
work we know that we know they don't
work look what we have look what we
have elections don't work man look I try
to elect people all the time and they're
still black people here there's still
brown people here in this country gez
Louise there's one sitting at the table
advocating for elections for crying out
loud look around you there's black
people everywhere that's what Greg
Gutfeld really means here that's what he
really means here you can't trust
elections because elections don't do
what I want if I don't get the results
that I want then elections don't work
they don't work if I don't get the
results that I want we have a moderate
president and we have crime exploding
everywhere we had a Democrat president
promised that he was going to be
moderate promised that he was going to
unite the country and now we have a
terrible education system we have no
border we have crime everywhere every
facet of society is in Peril and in
chaos because our elections don't matter
compl oh so you're what you want to do
is get the white people all rounded up
to go fight and commit violence against
black people because elections don't
work
H seems like it seems like that's what
you're saying Greg you pie of trash what
a piece of [__] garbage this guy is
it's a goddamn shame that we got to sit
and listen to these [__] idiots isn't
it Jesus [__] Christ and no one calls
them out for what they truly are Greg
gutfield is a [__]
Nazi what Greg gutfield is talking about
is [__] genocide he's talking about
going to war and killing people black
people that's what he's talking about
black and brown people that's what he
wants Greg [__] challenge me that's
what you're saying dude you're saying
hey man uh we had to get rid of slavery
with a war and now that we're the
oppressed and they're the oppressors
white people black people we need to go
to war with them now we need to go to
war with them and we just need to get
rid of them because elections don't work
because the elections that we have
doesn't do what I want and get rid of
the people that I don't
like that's literally what he's saying
and if if you don't like it [__] you I I
don't I don't care if you don't like
that that's my interpretation because
that's what he's
saying what the [__] he's
saying it's not hard to know these
things it really isn't uh Rachel boffer
opposed to this uh let me show you uh
what Rachel said Rachel said Chamberlain
could have told McCarthy how appeasement
ends here's how appeasement ends you see
that that's just right there oh man what
a great time in history that was when
Chamberlain went to Hitler and said you
know what let's happen let's make peace
let's make peace we we'll do a deal with
Nazis that's why the Democrats voted
against
McCarthy you [__] fools hell's wrong
with you that's why the Democrats voted
against
mcarthy let's see what else what else do
we got going oh I got to show you this
speaking of wan to be
dictators I'm not going to show you this
whole clip because it doesn't matter
Ronda santz is irrelevant I really just
want to make fun of him here I just
truly do we you know what we don't have
to play the audio I'm just gonna show
you the clip actually well just for the
people watching the audio um I'm I'm
gonna show you this but so you gotta
come over to YouTube and look at this
video of Ronda santis can you see if you
can catch what he does in like the first
five seconds of this thing this guy's so
[__]
disgusting yeah I you know what at first
when I first heard that he ate pudding
out of a pudding cup with his three
fingers I was kind of like H maybe maybe
that's true it might be true
maybe it sounds kind of gross though
like why wouldn't the guy take the foil
top off and fold it into a spoon and use
that as a spoon everyone knows that
anyone who's watched any YouTube shorts
or any Tik Tock hack shorts life hack
shorts like that's one of the first ones
that it shows you in the algorithm you
know that right like literally the first
the first thing they show you if you
ain't got a spoon and you got a pudding
cup is you just fold the goddamn foil
top into a spoon I'm not kidding you go
look it up if you don't know this and
you use that as a spoon not your [__]
fingers Ron Jesus Christ but after this
clip and after all the clips of him you
know wiping snot on people have you seen
these clips in Iowa like [__] blow
his nose into his hand and then he's
like wiping it on someone like someone's
shoulder [__] gross as
[__] everyone's everyone's saying show
us show us I want to point out hillbilly
here on on Twitch is our is a new
moderator on chit so so thank you for
Andre and hillbilly for keeping them all
keeping them all in line over there on
Twitch I I appreciate the moderators
over on Twitch as well as on YouTube and
I appreciate everyone who's signed up
we're still going through that list and
we we have new moderators adding every
day you see them in the chat here give
them some love while they're going
around but I'm going to show you I'm
just hanging you a little bit you know
what I mean in suspense that's why I
flip it back and forth so you can see
the pause and then I go to this and then
I go like here and then I go to this
it's just a little trick we do to keep
you hanging right you know what I mean
here is here's Ronda Santa so watch this
watch this the very
beginning he wiped his snot on his own
face did you see it watch this watch oh
my God he's got a big Boog oh there's
the Boog wipe it on my face are you
kidding me look at this [__] watch this
guy H
snot on my cheek he wants the snot on
his cheek you know what I
mean who does that who does that dude
listen I'll admit there's sometimes I
got a stray snot right you know what I'm
talking about it's allergy season it's
kind of cold maybe you start to sneeze a
lot your arms start Watering your nose
is kind of running you feel like [__]
you know what I'm talking about and
sometimes you got a stray snot you're
out somewhere you really ain't got
access to a Kleenex or a napkin or a
paper towel or even a little bit of
toilet paper or something you're kind of
stuck in a situation where that snot is
running out of your nose right and that
some [__] is g to get down in your
mouth if you don't get a hold of it
right you know what I'm talking about
you know what I'm talking about this is
a human thing everyone goes to this but
when you wipe the snot off your nose
right you don't [__] put it on your
face what I mean he's got some [__]
you know cheap ass suit here on but
goddamn Ron everyone knows you stick
your hand in your pocket or you kind of
you know get your hand underneath your
suit coat and wipe it on your shirt so
no one can see it because you know you
got your suit coat over it everyone
knows this right you don't wipe the snot
on your face what the [__] I'm not
kidding that's what this guy does watch
I don't even care about the clip I don't
even care about the like what he's
saying in it I just want to show you
here it is who put it right there right
there on his cheek like literally like I
don't know have you ever been in
construction when you got like a a a a
when you're trying to dry wall or you're
trying to spackle a wall and you dip you
dip the you you dip the knife in the
Spackle and you spackle it on the wall
you know what I'm talking about the fill
in the
hole that's what Ron's doing here he is
spackled snot all over his face watch
this
[Music]
guy there we go what the [__] and this
guy wonders why this guy wonders why
he's not gonna be president of the
United States that could be why people
are like whoa what the [__] is that
that's [__] gross but let me show you
let me show you a better scene this is
at the same [__] place Ronda Sanz is
trying to speak at this thing this is
like some kind of [__] law
enforcement thing where a bunch of cops
get up and you know didle Ronda Sanz
because Ronda Sanz is a goddamn fascist
and these cops are like yeah we want to
rough up black people that's what we
want we want to be able to do that
Governor D santis lets us do that yeah
but the funny part is in the clip you
can hear Laura
lumer yelling and screaming into her
bull into her bull hor from outside the
building look I'm no fan of lur lomer
here I [__] hate that trunt okay I
can't stand her she's such a [__]
liar she's such a [__] what a
[__] bonehead Lauren lomer is but
I'll tell you I never thought I'd say
this but Laura Laura don't stop the
crazy please don't stop the crazy it's
delicious watch
this you are never going to be president
of the United States of
America you are never going to be
president Donald Trump you have $5
million cash on hand you're an absentee
governor and you need to drop out and
endorse president Trump who's sitting
inside a New York City courtroom today
shame on
you no this is my oh now now this
security comes and touches her are
trying to touch her which yeah you
really shouldn't be doing that yeah you
shouldn't be trying to touch people even
if it's you know Lauren Lum she's
yelling and screaming which I'm listen
I'm not opposed to opposed to protest
I'm not opposed to Laura lomer yelling
and screaming right I'm not opposed to
that yeah I'm [__] sure especially if
she's at a Ronda STIs event with a shirt
of Trump's mug shot that says Never
Surrender on it
hilarious hilarious that is keep going
watch this this is is [__] great no
it's not I have a ticket for the event
you're being Tres I have a ticket for
the event I have a ticket for this event
I love how she's talking to them but
she's still talking into the [__]
megaphone uh Laura please do not stop
showing up at Rhonda Santa events in a
[__] shirt of trump with his mug
shots saying Never Surrender on the
shirt it's [__] great it's [__]
hilarious keep going I love the wedges
that you're driving down in between the
Republican party there's nothing better
there's nothing more laughable and
hilarious than this please keep going
please please keep fighting against your
own [__] party's interest because
that's what we need is we need them to
be fighting each other and Stoke that
Civil War it is delicious delicious and
speaking of the Never Surrender shirt I
got to show you this video I'm not gonna
make it to all the rounds here but I'm
going to try to show you this video here
if I can find it speaking of the never
the Never surrender the good liars ran
into someone uh I think it was in Iowa
over last weekend I believe uh is where
they ran into this person and they had a
Never Surrender shirt on and it is oh my
God it is so [__] great and I want to
show you the body language of the person
uh who is wearing the Never Surrender
shirt I want to show you what it means
because it's white guy language it's
white guy body language it really is
totally 100% white dude White dude
[__] body language on this guy if I
can find it [__] where is it hang on
we're going to get to it we're going to
get to bonehead here soon I promise uh
Gabe Sanchez is in the background he's
getting the um he's getting the assets
ready everyone's waiting on bonehead
it's gonna happen it's coming I promise
Bon head's on its way if I can find this
[__] clip H let's just go to the good
liars page good liars good liars I had
this let's
see
they have this clip again of a person in
and there's several clips that they do
they always are doing these videos it's
always great clip but this one in
particular is the one that I want to
show here it is here's why do all these
white dudes look the same hang
on why do all these white dudes look the
same huh why do they always look the
same you know what I'm talking
about why do they always look like this
why why do they always look like this
this here is
U here here's here's George in Iowa with
his wanted never surrendered shirt on H
but good liars is gonna ask him about
this I don't know why they always look
like this let's let's go so what is that
that's best president the United States
all right that's Donald Trump with his
mug shot right says Never Surrender
Never Surrender okay that is a picture
of him surrendering to Georgia
authorities though
right he's the best president of America
okay but that literally is a picture of
him surrendering right y okay
yep did you catch the white guy language
did you catch it did you catch the white
guy language let me go back and show you
let me show you the white guy language
okay after he points this out this guy
thinks he's this guy at first thinks he
might be an ally right he's got a
microphone he's talking all these
trumpers he really ain't saying
something derogatory at first about
Trump he's pointing at his T-shirt cuz
t-shirt is so [__] cool here is here
is
um let me show you the white guy
language watch this Donald Trump with
his mug shot right says Never Surrender
Never Surrender okay that is a picture
of him surrendering to Georgia
authorities though right okay so now
that this guy realizes all of a sudden
that oh oh this guy's not on my side oh
uhoh uh oh right this guy now sees the
good liars is a threat so let's see what
this guy says and does watch closely
what he does with his hand and the
shoulder
sure he's the best president of America
he's the best president in America and
he touches him he puts his hand on his
shoulder shakes him a little bit say
he's the best president in America and
what he's looking for is for this guy to
confirm that because if you don't
confirm it I'm to than you cuz look at
my sunglasses and my manga hat my Never
Surrender shirt this is white guy
language for I will kick your ass if you
don't agree with me because what I say
is right even though there's no facts to
back it up and you just totally proved
me wrong and made me look like an
[__] on camera with a microphone oh
my God that's what that language is
that's what it is that's what it is and
funny part is they don't back down and
this guy gets had lach okay but that
literally is a picture of him
surrendering right
yes
[Laughter]
yep oh my God so thank you to this
gentleman and thank you to Laura lomer
for absolutely throwing the brakes out
in front of you and jumping on every
single [__] one of them thank you so
[__]
much it makes me feel delighted this
morning uh as we go into bonee head of
the week so here's what we're going to
do we're going to go to break when we
come back we come back we should have
bon head as soon as possible don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul goar and thanks to my new product
Hardon blanket I've got you covered
Parton blanket specifically Works to
make you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup hard
and blanket will protect you too hard
and blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$999.99 actual pardon's not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast wellcome welome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
we're going have bon head of the
week coming up here very very
soon but I want to I want to give
you um there's going to be a bon head a
bonehead of the week I'm still waiting
on some of the um assets from Gabe
Sanchez Gabe Sanchez is going to be
joining us in just a few
minutes but before we get to bonee head
I want to get to this Bon head because I
don't think there's so many this week
that I don't think this one's going to
make an appearance this boneh head right
here the my pelow Nazi do you remember
this guy Mike Lindell he does interviews
without his pants on I'm not kidding he
he takes his pants off I'm sure he
doesn't even have pants on for this
interview on Steve bannon's war room but
he admits to Steve Bannon here that he's
[__] broke he spent every single last
dime of his money and his fortune to try
to act like Donald Trump was the
president of the United States oh man
ain't that a shame ain't that a [__]
shame oh man we should just all be
really upset that Mike Lindell spent
every single last time of his [__]
money on Donald Trump should we no we
should not we should be encouraging this
please Elon spend all your [__] money
on defending the rightwing and Donald
Trump do that please do that please do
that Mike Lenell please destroy your
fortune that would be great Haron Hitler
go ahead spend your fortune defending
Trump and losing your entire [__]
fortune Rudy Giuliani please if you
could spend what money you got left on
defending Donald Trump that would be
absolutely fantastic that would be great
if all of you could go flat [__]
broke but let's listen to Mike Lindell
how he now can't even get an attorney
because he has no money left whatsoever
I don't even know how he's doing his
show honestly I I don't know how they
haven't [__] taken this set from him
but let's let's listen um all the
lawyers we have for my pillow and uh
myself in the lawsuits with the laware
with dominion and smartmatic they uh
just filed in federal court that uh to
drop uh to drop us as our attorneys and
um and this comes from uh the lawfare
basically and from the media the attacks
on my pillow what American Express did
uh take just devastating our credit and
we I we have to I can't pay the lawyers
we can't pay there's no money left to
pay
them boo [__] who oh my God boo
[__] who this is what happens when
you run around the country trying to
sell [__]
lies and you defame person after person
after person you probably commit federal
crimes in the meantime this guy had his
[__] cell phone taken in Hardy's
drive-thru
by the FBI he's trying to stop them from
getting inside that cell phone and that
ain't working either I don't know if he
couldn't pay those lawyers or
what but this guy's being sued by De
dominion and
smartmatic and he and for for a lot of
[__] money a lot of money this guy's
broke he's flat broke his Fortune's gone
he had auction off my pillow soon there
will be no my pillow I mean maybe he be
able to sell the name and take that
money and maybe pay off some of his debt
pay off some of the lawyer debt that
he's got I don't know who knows but who
gives a [__] [__] Mike Lindell [__] him
[__] him and his lies and his [__]
this is [__] around find out season is
what it is and I keep telling you over
and over and over time and time again
look Donald Trump's day is coming we
just have to be ready and we have to be
ready to fight we have to keep fighting
every single
inch because they're not going to give
up they're going to spend whoever's
[__] money they have to spend they're
going to take your grandmommy's money
money your Papa's money they're [__]
they're going to mortgage their house to
give it to Trump because he'll go broke
they're all GNA go [__] broke here
chasing
Lies when all these son of a [__] had
to do was in December of 2020 just admit
the [__] truth Donald Trump [__]
lost that's all they had to do that was
it that's all they had to do was admit
Donald Trump loss just like in 2016 when
when the electorial college and the
State Certified their votes Hillary
Clinton and all the Defenders of Hillary
Clinton who were kind of getting in a
territory where they were like oh she
actually won they admitted she [__]
lost she [__] lost it ain't how you
want the election to work it it would be
great if we changed it because we I
would much rather have the popular vote
actually decide presidential elections
in this country any of them really but
the presidential one in particular but
that ain't how it [__] works is it is
it just like it ain't how it works with
the 14th is it is
it stop being stop being distracted by
[__] that ain't real otherwise you might
end up like Mike Lindell
here who chased around a [__] lie for
years and years and years and spend his
entire Fortune trying to convince people
in the country that the lie was the
truth when it wasn't and he knew it he
knew it so [__] Mike Lindell and boo
[__] who keep going [__] I hope Fox
News goes bankrupt I hope Newsmax I hope
o goes [__] bankrupt over this [__]
over these [__] lies [__] them [__]
them [__] them [__] them it's ridiculous
we got to stand around and have these
conversations about these
[__] but we do oh by the way
um I'm I'm waiting for gab Sanchez to
come on let's see how he's doing with
the assets here I'll check on those man
they're not there yet he's getting
closer I promise we're going to do Bon
of the week here very soon I promise you
that yeah and we got the Bon heads of
the week you know we do I don't even
actually know who won but speaking of
another bone end here's another clip I
want to show you you might recognize
this guy well there's no fly on his head
so you might not recognize him without
the fly but let's see what he has to say
about the house uh the house Republican
situation
speaker do we have a new speaker in the
house
no uh I think I'm in Randy f
area Congress who's your
Congress is it Randy yes let me tell you
what I'm g a round of applause for
Congressman Randy fastra he is one of
the
finest uh
conservative men of faith and conviction
okay so he's a Nazi I don't know if you
got that if Mike Pence is like a round
of applause for this conservative man of
Faith then he's definitely a [__]
Nazi keep going I've ever met it so
thank you for sending such a good decent
man
uh no we don't have a new speaker
yet frankly uh I I'm still scratching my
head about last week oh he's still
scratching his head he has no idea Mike
Pence has no idea what happened last
week let me let me give you a clue of
who Mike Pence is okay Mike Pence is the
guy who was told by Donald Trump look
you're gonna make me dictator and King
okay that's what the [__] you're going
to do and Mike Pence is like well I
really don't think I can do that and
Donald Trump's like yes you are and Mike
Pence went on a months long search
months long
search of how he could make Donald Trump
the dictator and King and every single
time he tried to uncover a way that he
could make Donald Trump dictator and
King and capitulate to him because he's
an
authoritarian every single time he
overturned those rocks he found a
federal prison sentence under underneath
those rocks so Mike Pence did the right
thing and decided it would be not good
to capitulate to Donald Trump and and
see him as a dictator and King what are
you talking about what happened last
week Mike you know what happened last
week Kevin McCarthy didn't do what Trump
wanted which was shut down the
government and instead he didn't have
the opportunity to have just a
mass of his supporters to come hang
Kevin McCarthy he couldn't get maglites
to go to Washington to hang Kevin
McCarthy like he did you because that's
what he did to you you wouldn't do what
he wanted so he sent his toothless uh
spread necks then gravy seals to the
capital to hang you but he really didn't
have that opportunity with Kev so what
he did to Kev is vacate his seat because
he didn't do what he wanted you got it
now are you clear on that let's see if
you're clear on that look I I had lots
of I led the house conservatives when I
was in Congress I did I had lots of
fights with the Republican leadership on
spending issues when I was there I had
lots of fights with the Republican
president on spending when I was there
you could you can ask him he remembers
it most of the time right I fought
against the Wall Street bailout I fought
against big spending program but never
never would I ever have considered
partnering with the
Democrats to throw out a Republican
leader it to me it just was
unconscious look no one joined the
Democrats you [__]
idiot why in the [__] can't they get
this straight the Republicans called the
vote to vacate because Donald Trump
wanted to vacate the seat because Kevin
McCarthy didn't do what he wanted to do
which was shut down the
government he wants he wants the house
not to govern that's what he wants he
wants dysfunction and Chaos why don't
they understand this Jesus Christ they
act like they don't know who Donald
Trump
is what the [__] they act like they
don't know who he is he wants chaos he
wants absolute destruction that's the
whole point that way he can stand up and
say well I'll fix it now I caused all
this destruction and Chaos I'll fix it
now how does Mike Pence not know this oh
that's right he does he's just full of
[__] eight Republicans partnered with
all the Democrats in the Congress that
being said uh I'm confident I'm
confident my old friends and colleagues
in Congressman sorted out we get new
leadership I just all right all right I
can't I can't we'll get new leadership
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah just like you're gonna be
president of the United States okay good
one
Mike I I know it's hard to hear because
he was in like a Hallmark store there
with mother I don't know if they were
shopping or something and he's
you know he can't go in a room with a
woman without mother right he can't be
in a room you can't trust Mike Pence in
a room alone with another woman I mean
why else would he not be able to go into
a room with another woman I I mean I
don't know I don't think there's any is
there a reason why a grown ass man other
than that can't go in a room with
another woman other than he can't be
trusted I mean think about that it's the
only reason I can think of so he's there
with Mother he they're shopping for I
don't know stuffed animals or [__]
cards or whatever
um he doesn't know who the congressman
is from the the area that he's that he's
campaigning in great great play for the
presidency great play for the
presidency okay good one Mike all right
there's your Mike Pence moment that'll
probably be the last Mike P Pence moment
you get in a long time
here a long time coming okay let's um
you know we got a little bit of time
here I'm waiting on Sanchez where are
you where are you ready let's see if
he's ready because I really want to dig
into Liz Cheney too ah you know I pissed
off the the the chat about Glenn earlier
now oh he's got man he's he's really on
it here okay uh I really pissed off the
chat earlier some of you some of you
have come to know that what Glenn said
about the 14th Amendment is absolute
[__] [__] uh and it's not real and
it's not going to happen in you should
just move on to things that matter and
things that you should pay attention to
to get stoked to get engaged and not to
breed discouragement we don't need to
breed discouragement uh and which only
breeds disengagement see if you get
discouraged you get disengaged in your
democracy and what we don't need to have
happen in our country is for people to
get disengaged in our democracy because
they're discouraged um so you need to
move on to things that are encouraging
like watching the House Republicans
absolutely destroy themselves that would
I mean that might work I don't know
maybe it won't maybe it will maybe you
won't believe me until it actually
happens but you can just go ahead and
doubt me just keep doing it and keep
dissenting too I like descent um I like
when people challenge me and have to
challenge my view I like when my views
are challenged see that's a thing in
this country that not a lot of people do
anymore you know they they're not
they're not able to defend their
positions they're not able able to
defend their views and then when they
can't defend them and because they're
wrong is the main reason uh when they
can't defend them and they're wrong then
then you know normally someone like
admits they're wrong and after they
defend their what the hell is going on
here what the [__] this guy always with
the background changing I tell you what
what in the goddamn hell I thought he
hit you're you're backwards again what
the hell's going on over backwards
what the hell's going
on I I noticed you've been changing your
background here like tell tell us the
story about tell the audience why you're
you're experimenting with the background
while I get the bone well you know I'm
just trying to find that dick Shadow you
know oh really yeah it's like I can't
quite get it I got little dinosaurs but
they're not quite doing it yet you'll
never have the dick Shadow a lot of
people don't know there's a there's a
dick on my wall here yeah and a lot of
people like to point out the it's got a
bush too it's even it it's a it's all
natural yeah a lot of people like the
dick Shadow that's why I've kept it no
the reason the reason that I was
switching on the back with the
background was because I was like oh you
know the the Wall's nice but like it's
very limiting to like where I I have to
like sit at an angle kind of thing and
we here and I was like I want you know I
got stuff to put up so I you know put up
some got my on air sign there I got some
books got some trinkets you know some
chachies wait a second do I got the
right one in here I don't know if I have
the right one in here which one are you
talking about I may have put the wrong
ones back in here let's
see yeah I sure I sure as hell did I'm
in the wrong SP oh man come on it's
clearly labeled man know what the hell
is going on a pain in the ass what a
pain in the ass anyway I figured I was
like Hey I want to add a little
character yeah
to uh to the set you know as big step s
big step fan said yesterday you know I
asked Gabe if those are ban books and I
did say yes uh there are ban books the
whole thing the whole thing all ban
books it's all like
Evolution book week right you know it's
band Book Week oh is it yeah you didn't
know that no I didn't know that you
haven't been paying attention to the
library of democracy then I I didn't I
didn't know that this was uh the band
Book Week yeah it's band Book Week um
and you can go watch videos on Library
democracy's YouTube channel if you want
they've got a good video on all the top
10 band books over there so what band
books do you got back there in the
background which ones are they um so
I've got media son's when every argument
I've got uh Frank wichs a beautiful
question uh emotional design which
Republicans don't know what that is oh
okay uh I've got is that why they want
to ban it because they don't know what
it is yeah they they don't they're like
critical race theory that sounds scary
let's ban that yeah uh I've got a book
called hooked here which is uh it's a
product design book again it means you
have to use your head in your brain not
the type of hook that you would get Matt
Gates on a dysfunction meds that's
that's what I was about to say I'm like
hooked sound this sounds like a story
from the Matt Gat Saga where he's on the
house floor showing uh showing other
Representatives uh videos and pictures
of the of the underage girls that he fck
see we knew that's the other well I'll
we'll talk about this in the yeah in the
in the Bon head of the week yeah well um
why but no one is what are you doing
what's going on I have no idea I'm I'm
put the right ones in right I think so
but I think I'm [__] it up every time
man this is not going well for me oh my
God no no it's it's the right I believe
it's the right ones um yes I'm [__]
it up I'm totally jacking this up oh my
God what a worthless piece of [__]
somebody says or Scotty B says need the
Whiteboard now I would however Oh you
mean you go back to the Whiteboard that
you had before yeah yeah the only
problem with that is you don't see this
wall and if it's on this wall you're
going to catch the reflection of that
light now I've been noticing that too
that you've been switching your desk
around too I've literally I move so I
had it at the original position and then
I swapped at 180 so now I'm in a
different position so you're like doggy
one day and missionary the other exactly
how is how is this going over over there
by the way when you're switching
positions like that well you know it
takes a little bit of work like you got
to ease into it you can't just like you
know switch right away you got to like I
give everyone complaining yesterday that
we're at zero days does this mean we're
at we're at I think we were at zero days
like 10 minutes ago okay good
um but I have I had the desk over here
behind me and then I flipped at 180 and
then I was like well I got this corner
and I tried before but I was like I
don't want to be in the corner like I
don't want to look like I'm isolated in
the corner so I got this corner
bookshelf here which some stuff as I
pointed out you did the old Switcheroo
on me here on you did a little bit of
switching around I wasn't sure how it
was I I want to point out that the
reason I pulled a switch r on the AC the
alpha cuck for today is actually thanks
to kayin she sent me a message oh and
that is why I see I had to make a little
fix little little little Quick Change
had a switching people around one person
was already in there but I had to move
to a different category I got you well
let's just do this let's do let's just
do a rough transition here
wow boy Dam you just switch us yeah that
was really rough that was like that was
that's not easing it in no no I will say
it's more rough than me switching
positions here in the room okay I got
you I got you well here's our Bon heads
of the week representative George Santos
Donald Trump
and former speaker Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McChicken H so these are our contestants
so let's get to it bonee head of the
[Music]
[Applause]
week bone head of the week it's been
it's been a it's been a while since um
we've been on screen you you haven't
made an appearance this week I know this
week has been crazy I know well you know
you know you you did uh great shows on
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday that I
watch I watch part of them I didn't
watch the whole thing but I watch the
majority of them while I'm editing and
stuff but then I gotta go take my walk
you know what I mean Oh I thought you
were gonna say you gotta go take your
[__] well I maybe yeah you know maybe
code code word got to take a walk you
know what I mean
um you're like take my daily walk AKA
got to get my metam musil in so I can
have my normal movement walk within my
bowels well speaking of bowel movement
Donald Trump ended
up on the uh bonee head oh my God
there's so many things that this guy
this week could be on bonehead really
honestly I'm surprised that he didn't
actually win that is if you're not if
you're new Bonet a week you know that we
go through all the losers first I will
say this it was relative well it was yes
it was close but I forget I think it was
YouTube he won on Twitter right or I
mean YouTube he won on YouTube he won on
YouTube and I think Kevin McCarthy won
on Discord by the way okay I'm just
gonna say it publicly so we have it on
the record yeah go ahead you need to
make sure that the deadline for the
timer is set to 12 hours or else I have
to do the [__] math
in my head and I got to enter in the
number total and what each one is and
then do the division and then so here's
the problem with the Discord poll here's
the problem with the Discord there's
nothing less than 24 no well there is
but it's much shorter than 12 hours how
long is it it's like eight hours or
something God that's plenty of time not
enough time plenty of time
so go I have to you know I have mean to
find a Community member that is a mathem
that way they can do the math for no
it's fine I've got I've got a Google
spreadsheet that's doing the math for me
but I have to go in oh so it's this and
ient that in so you got you got
artificial intelligence helping you here
me I got to add up the total and then I
got to put each individual value in
there he's got to add he's got to
subtract he's got a dude man I I didn't
I'm not I'm I didn't agree to go back to
school okay yeah well that is true I use
my
division very sparingly okay well you
know that that makes sense that makes
sense so everyone should be happy that
like look my brain power is reserved for
certain things yeah and and doing no I
love math but if I can make it easy for
myself meaning the timer is set to less
than 24 hours so it's already set to
Value just automatic if it tells me the
percentage that'd be great I hear you
I'll make that consideration yes Terry
wants to know can you vote on both
platforms yeah you can sure look yeah
it's rigged it's riged yeah it's rigged
it's rigged you could you could vote how
am I how but here's the thing here's the
thing is this isn't like the
presidential election where I'm keeping
track of your your voter registration on
each poll so how the hell am I supposed
to I mean now I can set it I can really
rig the poll on Discord because I can
set the Discord poll where you can vote
as many times as you want but I set it
to where you can only vote once so like
unless you have multiple accounts and
you'll be able to trick the system same
way on YouTube you know you'll be to
you'll be able to commit election fraud
on YouTube or Discord if you want
speaking of election fraud um and
speaking in fraud in general this guy's
committing tax fraud and he's admitting
it right out in the open now I love it
the chicken [__] here isn't going to
return the New York because I think the
reason why is because he keeps he kept
doing these little things where he'd
come out with the press and he' say
really stupid [__] were these I was I
was curious were these happening because
they're happening before I wake up so
uh because obviously they're on the East
Coast so are they happening wait wait
wait this one happened at
12:57 was that it said yeah that's what
it says right up here oh okay so it's
like
95 I was up for that one I was up for
that you might still be asleep who knows
I might have been I might have been
doing I might have been switching the
desk run hey it's good be
so he's either he's either doing what
was that or switching the desk around or
sleeping that's all there is he do even
have time to take a [__] or eat at this
point it's like I I I eat on just the
laughter alone okay so is he I guess my
question is is he going into the
courtroom they're having their little
like Pow Wow in front of the judge and
then he comes out and goes fake news
fake news or is he going in is he
leading in like a warm-up going fake
news all that all that all and then they
go into the courtroom all of that all he
goes in on the breaks he comes out and
he gives his stupid little speech but
honestly I think that the political
Campa
mhm they were like this is really bad
and here's why this is really bad is
because this guy is coming out in front
of America and he's whining and bitching
that one of his houses is only worth $18
million like that's not a good look like
most Americans are like groceries are
high gas is high my my [__] pay went
up but not enough you I can barely
afford this barely afford that here this
[__] is coming out in front of
the American people like my house is
worth way more than 18 million like oh
okay that's really gonna land flat yeah
I mean this whole like because you got
to remember the number went up from
Monday to Tuesday so on Monday he said
yeah I just want to point out somebody
asked if I sleep till noon no I [__]
wish I'm on the west coast so I'm three
hours behind whatever is happen a nap
after the show he takes a nap after the
show but I wake up I go to the gym and
then I come back I switch the desk
ground all right so what I do want to
say what I do want to say is when it
comes to this on Monday he was like it's
wor he goes he goes
um Mar Lago is worth a billion dollars
okay not 18 million like everyone says
the corrupt Democratic judge what about
that [__] clerk
then then on Tuesday actually Tuesday I
think is when he said the clerking and
then on Tuesday he was like Mara Lago
not worth $18 million actually worth 1.5
billion ion and you're like whoa how did
we add another half a billion dollars on
that's some hell of inflation is yeah I
was like I don't know what kind of boy
math you're doing right now I called my
bank I called my bank and I was like hey
if Mara Lago increased by a half a
billion dollars overnight I want to know
I want to get a [__] I want to get a
mortgage on my house right now I want to
know let me refinance on you know let me
refinance so Donald Trump goes in and
he's like it's not worth 18 million it's
worth a billion the next day he's like
oh the only way to up this is to go from
1 billion to 1.5 billion I was really
hoping that on two or on Wednesday that
he was going to be like it's worth4
billion
dollar because you've got Don junor he's
gonna get to the trillion he's defin I
would imagine eventually I mean if up a
half a billion dollars a day it's it's
gonna get there kind of quick right yeah
I would also imagine that when it comes
to the value he's going to be like it's
almost as worth how much debt that I put
into this country while I was president
president because it's just it is
honestly madeup math it's Donald Trump
thinking it is but what people need to
understand is that back in two 2020 I
think 2020 they valued the property at
million right the company the company
Trump trump said hey our property is
worth this much money and remember in
this I think in this clip if not another
one is when he admits to committing
fraud right yeah well that's that's why
I wanted to play this clip because
there's so many there's so many [__]
clips of this guy this week of doing
stupid [__] and I mean they're all
they're all the like day one Monday day
two Tuesday day three Wednesday they all
more or less say the same thing right
he's corrupt it's a democratic judge
everyone else is out to get me it's not
worth James is a racist she she hates
white people that's what I'm saying she
hates white people that's what I'm
trying trying to say and by white people
I mean me I mean me she hates me I'm
white She Hates Me EXC excuse me excuse
me okay okay let me play you a song on
the world's tiniest
accordion and then he's like then he's
like Leticia James coming to get me
meanwhile Chris kais and Alina habba are
standing behind him being
like [__] you know Chris kis most of the
time through this whole thing like when
they take pictures of him he's [__]
smiling man he's happy as a l look he
got his got paid right he's gotten paid
for all this already so like he's like
yeah I'm happy as a lark I've already
been paid alen Hab she's not been paid
she she didn't she didn't even fill out
the paperwork correctly which she did
because they didn't want a jury trial
all she check she checked the check box
right and she also it's a I think it's a
$70 fee to pay for the
uh just Swit it no no it's a $70 fee to
submit right so they paid $70 they
looked at the checkbox and say jury no
jury jury no jury well $70 right now in
Trump's world I mean I don't know if you
heard about Mike andell and Rudy julani
but well $7 goes a long way right now in
Trump World but let's play this clip and
see why Grandpa here poopy pants is
admitting to tax fraud right out in the
open this is probably the dumbest thing
he did all week
got the judge to Value Mar
for
million what the smallest house in Palm
Beach is probably worth 50 million oh
boy okay okay so so he's saying that um
he believes that what he's saying is
[__] but let's let's keep playing
let's let's see if he gets to the tax
fraud part because he gets to it pretty
quick he's like yeah I commit a tax
fraud let's do that
and this is the biggest the best
anywhere the country there's nothing
like it so they put it down at 18
million and they said I I overvalued it
because we had it valued at a much lower
number than it's worth and by the way my
financial documents yeah are valued much
less than my actual value wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait is he saying is
he saying that he actually reported that
it was less worth than what he actually
believes it is is that is that what he's
saying yeah yeah that would that would
be it he he's he's admitting yeah in in
in front of everyone on on national TV
on Fox News especially right that Mara
Lago is not actually the Val is not
valued the same of what he disclosed as
right it's almost like he said it's
worth more well it's not like he said he
literally said it's worth more and on my
financial documents I said it was worth
less that's called uh fraud because when
it comes to paying your taxes if I owned
a property that was worth $1.5 billion
and then I said actually it's worth 27
million and I self-reported that value I
said to the IRS and everyone around hey
look my value has been assessed it's 27
million I'm only going to pay taxes on
the $27 million I I shouldn't have to
pay taxes on 1.5 1.5 billion that's
called fraud guys that's called fraud
right well the other thing too that a
lot of people aren't seeing in this case
is especially the testimony and
deposition from Michael Cohen we all
know this morning Trump has dropped his
lawsuit his half a billion dollar
lawsuit against Michael Cohen because he
doesn't want to be deposed didn't he
drop another lawsuit against the judge
of this case uh probably either that
they threw it out they they're trying to
get a stay on this case and a couple
others trying to quote presidential
immunity the reason why is because he's
been caught um giving nuclear secrets
away which is another boneheaded reason
that he could be on this [__] did you
see the so here's one thing did you see
the timing because yesterday so I was on
the show and we were talking about um
this it's what he say outside perimeter
is I think what they put in quotes they
said as the president he has
presidential immunity and this was just
another part of his job and but he's not
the president right exactly well you
tell them that so a lot of look they
live in delusions of grandeur so when
you look at this during the show
yesterday that I had uh we covered this
point where it says like on the outside
perimeter they had submitted to say that
Donald Trump uh should not be charged
for stealing presidential documents
because it was actually part of his job
as president no he's not president he
never read the briefs there's a reason
why Biden said do not give him any
security briefs anymore do not give do
not no banned you're done don't give him
classified information there's a reason
so on top of that I think I want to I
think like within an hour maybe less
that drops as like the court document
drops and then within an hour the ABC
News maybe maybe a little bit more than
hour but I want to say with an hour the
ABC news story breaks that Donald Trump
told some Australian billionaire who's a
member of the club about nuclear subs
and then that guy was like oh good day
great and then told all of his other
friends he told news outlets journalist
a hand I think I think the oh what was
the also told Jack Smith that he did
this too yeah yeah exactly I mean that's
that's kind of the real story here is
that Jack Smith knows this I I love the
timing where this goes out and whether
and it's possible that Jack Smith was
waiting on this and they're like look we
could drop this whenever we want Donald
Trump's like look we're going to file a
lawsuit or we're going to file a uh an
appeal to this and then Jack Smith was
like all right just [__] drop it I
guess send it to send it to ABC we're
going with it and just because it was
within such a short period of time where
they were like we think that he totally
should have been taking these documents
and these secrets and these classified
materials and then Jack Smith was like
actually do you guys know what he was
doing with those materials he was
telling people about it I actually
believe that Trump Trump's team broke
that to ABC because they're trying to
get ahead of this that's why they're
doing the presidential immunity that's
they're trying to get ahead of this
that's why that's why he wants that's
why he wants the government shut down I
mean all this stuff it's just it's just
like a waterfall of [__] around find out
on I just don't know who on the team was
like yeah that's a good idea Donald
Trump I mean I guess he's like he called
us John no look at look somebody
somebody close to Donald Trump not gonna
say it's me I'm John
Baron he's totally like good any press
is good press bad press good press even
even the emission of Espionage but I
want to show you a picture here because
I disparaged this Australian billionaire
his name is Anthony Pratt apparently um
earlier because my question is how do
all these billionaires look like such
[__] how is this even possible even seen
a yeah that that makes sense look that
makes sense how old is this
[__] does this billionaire not
have money to afford to think look like
this do you think he's older or younger
than Trump um I'm gonna say older but
you know he's got kind of this look
almost I'm not I'm gonna say this and I
know this might piss a lot of I might
lose this show over what I'm about to
say um it almost is like Trump and
Murdoch rert Murdoch [__] and had a
baby and this guy's the baby I'm not
gonna lie that's what it really looks
like to me doesn't it to you okay I
found out okay what's the
he is because Trump is what 78 right now
yes I think I believe so this guy is 15
years
younger what yeah no way he looks he
looks like he looks like he's 15 years
older news fake news fake news there's
no way this guy is 15 years younger than
Trump he was born in 1960 this guy looks
like [__] man how how does a billionaire
look like [__] like this like even Jeff
Bezos you you know you know the old Jeff
Bezos before he was like the richest man
in the world he's kind of puny look
nerdy now he's like all [__] buffing
[__] well you got billion dollars you're
like what do I do I buy a dick rocket
and I'll get buff right exactly but how
do these how do some of these
billionaires like Elon uh Trump pretends
to be a billionaire so I understand that
but this guy this Australian billionaire
how do they not afford to look look
halfway decent this guy looks like [__]
you know it's really it's really amazing
you think that if you had that much
money you would do every you're like
yeah I'll do like simple like Botox
treatment I'll do some collagen I'll
have a fitness trainer I have the best
nutritionist I have this I have that I
make sure that I live in a good area
where there's uh not a lot of uh Smog or
or you know uh uh Airborne kind of
ailments uh you know you would if I was
a billionaire because there's also that
guy who I think he lives out in here in
LA formerly a uh a tech formerly Tech
CEO and now he's trying to be
essentially like a vampire uh what yeah
there's I mean I mean this guy looks
like a vampire I'm not gonna lie well
yeah so the uh the guy I'm trying to he
by the name of Brian Johnson he's the
guy that's swapping blood with his
younger son and his older father and he
does all of these
crazy crazy wait wait wait what did you
say
yeah yeah he trades blood he's got a
blood boy and that's his son and he is
his father's blood boy dude there's a
whole thing people don't know about
Brian Johnson it's pretty crazy he's got
he's he's made hundreds of millions of
dollars uh working INX this is more
reason that we need to tax the rich like
this alone story we need tax the [__]
I've watched multiple videos from like
other creators who have gone to his
house and done
the full regimen in a day where he gets
uh red red light therapy on his body he
does this like the ball panning [__] yes
yeah same same thing then there's like
86 pills he takes he does a workout uh
routine he you know what he eats he does
hair stuff he does skin stuff he does
all this dude he's been watching Joe
Rogan's podcast way too much so so and
he's got this the whole thing is this
project that he's self-funded
and he's trying to study the human body
and he's using himself as a guinea pig
to say all right what if I do if I were
to you know put myself in the best
possible conditions he went from a I
worked all day I worked all night I
founded these companies and I I just
[__] rinded myself down to to nothing
and
then now he's like I'm G to use this
opportunity to give back by doing this
crazy kind of I want to live who who is
he giving to I don't know the community
Tech Community the idea I mean like the
amount of dude it's insane what I've
seen his routine be man it's crazy well
you know what else is insane you know
what else is insane that George Santos
is still a congressman that's [__]
insane that's insane so what was the
news this week with old Georgie Porgy
huh well you what what did we get this
week from GE one time former Treasurer
Nancy Marx turns out she was like yeah
guilty because she was being charged
wasn't she yeah she was being charged
and and I wouldn't be surprised if she
gives information when it comes
to George Santos's 13 felony count
indictment well uh some are surmising
that there may be more counts to come
because of her testimony oh yeah it is
possible so now we we'll see it's
amazing to it's amazing to see how
confident and naive or or I don't know
hubris we'll call it uh that his own
party and by party I mean his own team
are confident that he's like oh yeah
yeah Santos is totally fine nothing
nothing wrong he's doing great today
nothing to see here nothing to see it's
like that big fire it's the yeah the
meme yeah it's like everything's okay
everything's fine well there's
everything fine but then there's also
the one where um was it from Naked Gun I
forget which which film from but he's
like explosions fir like look it's all
good nothing to see here well here's the
story from citizens for anics crew it
says representative George Santos former
treasur pleads guilty to conspiracy to
deep fraud the US the United States that
is or us the US and admitted to listing
fake donations to last year's campaign
this was all an attempt to make it seem
like Santos had more support than he
really did wonder what it could be
now this is Republican 101 okay if this
is fraud lock them all up I'm not g I'm
not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie like
Donald Trump the no I'm dead serious
like no I'm dead serious if this is what
we're gonna do lock these people up for
listing fake donations or or having fake
donations so that they can attempt to
make it look like they have more support
than they really do I mean Donald Trump
does this [__] all the time where he's
like at a rally and they move the
cameras way the [__] in so that looks
like there's you know more than 10
people there I mean DeSantis does the
same stupid [__] I mean really honestly
lock them all up if this is what we're
gonna do yeah where where do those gold
bars come from I don't know like come on
guys at least be creative with it was in
my savings account yeah which originally
came from another third party chicken my
savings I got to move my check money
from my savings to my
checking come on man man come on man oh
boy but somehow somehow Santos and his
team are confident that Nancy marks have
nothing on nothing on Santos well and I
won't tell you how I know that because I
don't want to give it away oh okay so
you you've got Insider information is
that what you're I've got sources a
source yeah that would indicate that uh
that George Santos is totally fine he's
not even worried about it not even
worried okay well good you know who else
shouldn't worry about allegations again
him against them this dishonorable
mention Matt gets I almost I had him as
the alpha cuck did you really but I made
a last minute switch because kayin
brought up a story to me and I was like
oh this is much more Alpha cck than Matt
Gates Matt Gates gets the dishonorable
mention because not only yeah in in some
ways I'm like oh yes Bravo I'm glad you
did what you did um it Matt Gates
throwing just exposing the just putting
the dirty laundry out for everyone to
see but
exposing the Republican party for what
they are saying the quiet part out loud
I love that they're concerned about the
budget now and this and that and they're
claiming that Donald Trump did all these
things when everyone's like oh yeah okay
great you said all these things let's go
back let's quickly fact check those
those claims that you made
um but the real
reason that I put Matt Gates on there
was because of
his doing lines of erectile dysfunction
medication and drinking Red Bull yeah
and the fact that this these are these
are stories dude homie's going to catch
a Madison cawthorne real quick I'm I'm
tell oh he's going to get C I'm telling
you I mean that because I also and I
also kind of want to call it the
Republican party it wasn't until Matt
Gates was like hey we should throw this
[__] into chaos we should we should
remove the speaker of Kevin McCarthy it
wasn't until that moment did people like
Senator Mullen here go oh you know what
I was privy to certain conversations
text messages phone calls emails videos
and photos of this guy committing a
problem you know what you know what's
funny cuz I'm going to play well let's
just play the clip here and I I'll show
you I'll tell you what I think about U
Mark Wayne here Mark Wayne Mullen the
senator used to be a representative but
he's now the senator of Oklahoma let's
listen you gotta think about this guy um
this is a guy that didn't have that the
media didn't give a time a day to after
he was accused of sleeping with an
underage girl and there's a reason why
no one in the conference came and
defended him because we had all seen the
videos he was showing on the house floor
that all of us had walked away of the
girls that he had leftt with he'd brag
about how he would crush Ed medicine and
and and Chase it with um with an energy
drink so he could go all night this is
okay okay wait wait wait wait Mark Wayne
Mark Wayne Mark Wayne did you just say
that Matt Gat showed you videos and
pictures of underage girls that he had
[__] on the house floor and you were
like enough for me I'm just GNA walk
away are you telling me that you care
about saving the children and about
sexualizing children so much that you
just couldn't muster up enough courage
to tell someone that Matt gats was
showing you child porn is that what is
that what he is telling us I think
that's what he's saying here he's
admitting he's admitting to the fact
that he was aware he had knowledge
of photos and videos of Matt Gates
sleeping with other women underage women
this the thing is the photos the photo
story was known right that was something
i' been talk that right now the video
aspect is something way different and
not only that but yeah so uh small rat
says uh he said Chase not snort now the
only reason you crush
up tablets instead of taking it hold
wait wait wait is you talking about V
aner right you're talking about you're
talking about boner pills right yeah
yeah okay wait only I wait how do you
know what you need to do with boner
pills how I mean how do you how do you
know this you just put it in your mouth
that's what she said or he who or he
whatever that's what they said right
look look the way that it works Tony
I've seen it on the commercials okay
I've seen enough blue chew ads on
[__] Twitter these days okay I got
you you just pop it you throw it back
right that's how you that's how you
would normally take a pill right and
then the fact that he said crushed it up
typically you don't crush up things
unless you're going to SN them right
what would you snort it with what would
you snort it with I mean you know I
don't I mean you tell me dude the fact
that he's like oh man I gotta I'm gonna
he's gonna go all night who knows he
might have been taking a little bit of
those uh the cocaine you think him and
Don Jr were double teaming with the
booger sugar I I mean if we if we think
if we think about yeah the conversation
that Madison cauthorne had uhuh on that
podcast fueled sex stories he said
cocaine fueled sex orgies they said do
you want to come over to little get
together turns out it was an orgy you
know these people who are like 60 70 80
years old you know look if you've got
problems with these sex ories maybe
introduce term limits okay get some
younger people in the batch so you can
[__] run them through but when you've
got someone like Madison caor who's
saying what I'm just saying I'm just say
why is why is it if you have term limits
only young people will be elected why is
that I'm just thinking younger people
but we're talking about Republican here
you think
repic like I don't know the idea that
you're look look this is like this is
like running around the country trying
to court young people and he's like well
I don't want anyone 18 to 25 to vote
like it doesn't you you you probably
have more young people than you do older
people I mean look you also have to
remember that during Co so many old
people [__] died because they
believed Co was a hoax so that's on them
so I would say that the remaining few of
older people are probably less inclined
to be running for office like a man sh
because you know why those people are
like oh [__] that [__] I'm just gonna
siphon off the government on my
retirement because socialism is great
when it benefits me so I think younger
people would actually be more inclined
to run some younger I mean especially
especially if we have the cocaine fi sex
orgies we get a also it would allow you
to get that young boy blood in there you
know that way you can do a little that
you know crazy Satanist Satanism type of
[__] but when you have this situ
the fact
that former representative now Senator
was privy to those videos photos and
convers just now telling us about it
just dude this this party is this party
is I will hold on to your secrets until
it benefits me politically and then I'll
come after you but we know that these
were these were things happening I want
to say when he was a freshman
representative so this is years ago that
Mullen has been sitting on on this
information was like well I love every
time every because Mark Wayne has been
on the the media circuit trying to
destroy Matt gats with this information
which everyone knows yeah and and
basically what he's trying to point out
what he's trying to trigger is a federal
investigation to get Matt gatz's uh
electronic devices because if they
actually have those electronic devices
they will find those images they will
find those videos and he's completely
[__] if they really do exist now I
will say I'm not sure if Matt Gant
should have been the dishonorable
mention here are everyone Who Matt G
showed child porn to and they said
nothing I'm not really sure but let's go
to the alpha cuck because we're running
out of time year but let's go to the
alpha cck here and let's see if this is
any less skey uh Elon Musk ended up
being the alpha cck I thought it was
gonna be Matt Gatson I thought Rudy
Giuliani was gonna be yeah I thought so
too I thought so too however however I
pulled an audible I got a message from
kayn and she was like hey have you seen
a have you seen this
um
the oh yeah last minute Alpha Cook
Change thanks to kayin she takes a bow
everyone you can thank kayin for this
one uh so there here let me get up the
actual tweet give me give me the link
here give me the link bring the link up
um while we're doing that there's there
is breaking news in the last half hour
ex Trump execu executive Jeff mcconnie
mccon mccan uh admits ex Trump CFO Allan
Weissberg asked for help in committing
tax fraud on more than one occasion
uhoh I love I love how they're like help
me commit tax fraud they're like well
all you got to do is uh value something
that less than you want let me show that
let me show here actually let me show
you a video from Donald Trump this is
how you do it and also this is how you
admit to it uh here's here's why Elon
Musk though ended up on boneh hend of
the week yeah
um at Matt Bender has it here he says um
did the guy famous for basically
accusing someone he didn't like of being
a pedo guy just suspend at Juniper after
she did the same thing to him is that
what's what's going yeah so so quick on
to background here Elon Musk called the
British cave diver the one who went to
go save those 13 TI boy the the 13 tie
uh boys the soccer players that were
stuck in the cave he went there because
his expertise was um cave exploration SP
spling all that stuff right spunking and
spelunking spunking spelunking sping
sping so that's his expertise he went
there to say like all right not this guy
this
guy's this guy was like Hey I'm gonna
send a little mini boy sub and you're
like wait why do you have a mini boy sub
and he's like don't ask questions P
guy and the reason that he called him a
ped guy was because the British uh Cave
cave diver and explorer was like uh I
don't need help from you and you have no
idea what you're doing please stay far
far away from this and leave it to the
professionals and Elon Musk
got so sensitive so triggered that he
called him a pedo guy then that the
British guy sued him and was like
there's no there's no
way
that you would uh there there there's no
there's no reason to believe that this
guyy is a ped you you defamed his name
they went to court I I don't think at
the end it was like any sold him for Su
him for millions and then I think they
settled for less than 50,000 or
something like that and Elon Musk ended
up getting out of the
[__] so that is why that is what uh
Matt binder is talking about now in this
one this is Juniper who's a Twitter
troll who's gone after Elon many times
you've probably seen their tweets before
I had like a quick like double tick I
was like wait why does that a username
sound familiar when kin brought it up
and
uh now they're suspended and the reason
is because Elon Musk the
grandm product designer that Elon Musk
thinks that he is remember remember the
last time that Elon Musk tried to design
something it was the check marks and
remember what happened he was warned he
was warned that something bad was gonna
happen it went great it went it went so
it went actually it went as good
as yeah you got to see the [__] thing
dude oh no oh oh it went over like a wet
fart and a white thong there we go okay
so is that what you were I was like oh
it went over it went over like a wet F
and a white thong exactly I was just you
know queuing you up okay so so at that
moment everyone including um the current
head of safety trust and safety at
Twitter said we can't do this because
what we're going to happen what what is
going to happen is what we've
seen is if we allow other people who are
not verified to pay for check marks
we're going to have unverified people
who are going to be pretending to be
people impersonating and this can cause
a lot of brand
issues and also uh reputation it's just
not going to be good and Elon Musk said
ah [__] it we'll do it anyway they did
it and surprise surprise and ended up
going the way that they that they
predicted then they like did it go like
his rocket in the air when yeah it went
and it exploded w
then yeah then then they were like oh
we're going to now introduce other check
marks it's like oh my God Jesus Christ
we got a gold we got a gray we got a
blue we got a this we got a that it's
like dude we don't need you had a system
before that was able to verify whether
they're real or not the whole time Elon
being like it's a way to verify there
aren't bots in the system Elon hasn't
done [__] to prevent the bots so then
fast forward to this week I think it was
like two days ago or yesterday M that
they finally implement mented this
change before when you added a link to
Twitter you would get a thumbnail and
you would get the metadata which is the
title in the source so you get contacts
like oh it's from political or it's from
Breitbart or it's from now it's just the
image now it's just the image and
there's a small overlay that says what
the what the website is here it is right
here yeah fortune.com but depending on
the image that you have like a dark
image that's used as a thumbnail
you have no context and nobody knows to
look at the bottom because there's
nothing that says like oh fortune.com
and here's the title so you could write
a caption and add a photo and have it be
a link to something I saw someone
yesterday say something about
um I think it was Elon Musk committed
murder in his home it was a man and it
was Elon Musk face and shots of his home
but the title was saying that he had
committed murder or something like that
this one a dead body they found they
found a dead body that's what it was and
this one is saying new scoop evidence
showing Elon Musk is a pedophile
mounting quickly and you don't know what
it's for but you have him smiling and
it's for a fortune.com article but you
don't you don't know otherwise you think
yeah it is what it is and that's the
fortune well yeah Fortune's The Source
here and then it and then it also has
the community notes here this is
true oh my God so Elon basically stepped
on a rake here is that what you're
saying oh okay oh my God that's um but
here's the thing is that not only did he
step on a rake he got really pissed off
oh man elon's such a little [__]
because here's what happened to Juniper
when he found out that jenniper used his
own system against him his own invention
really against him is he suspended
there's look there's a reason why us as
product designers design you actually
that's talked about the book hooked here
which is talk about this model of how
you get people to come back and keep
using your your app or your your your
product um but in in
that assessment of him thinking that
he's a product designer like it hurts me
as a product designer because I'm like
the the lack of awareness and
the feeling that that Elon Musk is
entitled and he's like oh what I say is
true and my my business acument is right
and also my sense of design is
unparalleled except anytime that Elon
Musk goes into the room and says I got a
I got an idea for this we're going to
design this thing this way it ends up
backfiring this is now the second if not
third time this is backfired on Elon
Musk when it comes to Twitter he came in
was like I'm gonna nobody said I could
do this but I did it anyway and it's
like nobody said you nobody said you
couldn't do it just just everyone said
you couldn't do it well well speaking of
not doing [__] well speaking of people
not doing stuff well it leads me to our
Bon head of the week winner former
speaker Kevin McChicken I mean McCarthy
uh he became our bonehead of the week as
you guys voted it's very clear why he's
the bonehead of the week yeah oh you
think I'm gonna say because he got
vacated is that is that what you think
I'm GNA say no that's not what I'm going
to say actually the reason why I think
he's the bonehead of the week is because
of this picture right here and this
picture right here is the reason why Jim
Jordan is going to soon be the bonehead
of the week because what actually
happened to Kevin McCarthy isn't because
he was a shitty speaker it's because he
was appointed speaker by the mango
musolini Jesus Donald Trump just like
Jim Jordan is gonna be appointed the the
authoritarian speaker to be in the place
of Donald Trump the mango musolini Jesus
after January 6 Kevin McCarthy went down
down to Mar Lago and got his Cheeto dust
knee pads on and kissed this guy's ass
and whatever whatever else he kissed to
make sure that he could be the speaker
of the house and Kev you made your own
bed you made your own bed and you should
sleep in it you piece of trash you piece
of trump Nazi trash we have to we have
to remember that that not only did Kevin
McCarthy go down to Mar Lago to do those
things you know
every moment a little sorry blowy um to
a to a Cheeto man uh but you have to
remember that Kevin McCarthy is
single-handedly the one that helped re
rehabilitate Trump's image and
normalized him brought him into the
discussion into the fold instead of
being like you know I mean obviously you
know conversations happen on January 6th
instead of this guy being like no this
guy is a poison he's given us a bad name
if as if we already didn't have a bad
name this guy is ruining us he's going
to be the destruction of this party and
Kevin McCarthy was like [__] it and went
to go work with him and I mean even on
Kevin McCarthy's way out he's like
trying to trash other mag Republicans
and not conservatives this and that it's
like dude you [__] made this mess you
allowed this to happen you
allowed that to germinate and and
overpopulate the party that you once
said was conservative
Republicans well you know without Kevin
McCarthy though doing all that you just
said we wouldn't have this great
internet moment right here of the new
acting Speaker of the House vacating the
seat of Kevin mcarthy let's watch it
Chad declares the house of recess
subject to the call of the
chair that is that is acting acting
speaker and Elf on the Shelf Patrick
McKenry of North Carolina
and until uh they take I don't know 20
rounds to vote Jim Jordan in so that's
that's another thing I was curious about
like they technically don't have to vote
because the rule is you vote when
there's the next election right so so
they could appoint yeah they could they
could use this acting uh appointment
that they used uh for McKenry here to
basically
slide in Jim I don't report sex Grimes
Jordan into that seat but Kev but
they're also but I think the really
important thing that they're trying to
do now is they're trying to slide
someone in maybe Jim Jordan Liz Cheney
says that you know she doesn't think
he's gonna uh that he's gonna get it
kininger says that he does think he's
going to get it but one thing I think is
important is that not only are they
trying to get this person in but they're
trying to get someone in and then remove
the ability to vacate the motion to
vacate the speaker so they want to get a
republican in and then say okay now that
they're in we don't want to allow anyone
to change that and we want it to stay
that way which if that does
happen I anticipate it's going to be a
massive rake step because in the next
election there will be those five seat
majority they had they'll probably lose
it and then who gets to come in Hakeem
Jeff if you don't have a motion to
vacate
anymore because they don't have the
foresight the future proofing to think
about oh if we do this what happens if
the Democrats take
control and that's and and I imagine
that could be and probably is a very
likely scenario that they're thinking
right now we'll fix it we'll be able to
destroy things right now and we'll
benefit ourselves yeah absolutely we'll
burn it all down we can't think maybe
two three years that no no no no no no
no they cannot see their nose despite
their face which is why Kevin McCarthy
is our bonehead of the week Gabe Sanchez
let's give
McChicken his
[Music]
[Applause]
doe oh Kev I'm so [__] happy for you
I really am I really am I'm happy for
you you got everything you wanted you
got everything you wanted there are so
many people in the Republican party
right now where I'm like man couldn't
happen to a shittier person got George
Santos on the brink of going to jail
probably with Nancy marks coming forward
to say I'm guilty I plead guilty you've
got Matt Gates you know getting people
to basically attack him again they're
gonna pull a c for the pedophile he is
then on top of that you got uh
uh who else you got you got I mean all
of
them michell he's [__] broke Rudy
Giuliani he's also broke he's trying to
[__] Sue Biden for a comment he made
during the 2020
debates it's just like it's like you
guys you guys have nothing so you're
trying to go back I mean they they are
stuck on the past Donald Trump stuck on
the past Michael Lindell stuck on the
past Rudy Giuliani stuck on the past
good they cannot move forward and think
head because that would mean that they
were Progressive and that just ain't a
thing for them guess what [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
them head of the week got it done we're
a little bit over time it's okay I got a
few announcements here though don't
forget to go follow Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel the link is down below
make make sure to get to his link tree
and go follow his YouTube channel
because you're not gonna want to miss
and there it is look at
that boom I didn't I didn't know we
still had it was in there dude it just
sit there boom boom go to youtube.com
gab Sanchez make sure you follow his
YouTube channel if you're on Twitch
follow him on Twitch as well you're
gonna want to catch his show what was
that live every single Tuesday Wednesday
and Thursday directly after this show
and you're not going to want to miss the
Tony Michaels podcast
especially if you want to see gabee
Sanchez on Friday so make sure to
subscribe and join us every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Facebook and twitch and come hang out
with us in the second hour on Friday and
let's do bonehead of the week why not
let's fing dunk on some some idiots boom
boom Gabe Sanchez you gonna have a are
you gonna have a good weekend are you
gonna have a good weekend uh yeah I got
I got my partner fam in town so we're
going to go do some stuff you know
family stuff go see some sites see some
things good yeah you know go check out
this the the the things that the people
talk about you know all the things the
things things oh here we
go W woo all right everyone have a great
weekend come back see you same time same
place on Monday don't do anything I
wouldn't do or do or do it surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
M's mebor head ass
speaking
I just wonder too I mean how come almost
everybody I know of that went to college
is a Biden suppor yeah and I don't
understand how everybody is a Biden
supporter if you just want the college
so what are they teaching in this
college are they teaching anything stuff
like inclusivity and expecting other
people I guess I don't know yeah woke
yeah a wokeness yeah I just wonder too I
mean how
come